I just like
I think I could just like borrow it
after one second
this scene from the bear season 2
episode 6 titled fishes is one of the
most suspenseful things I've seen on TV
in a long time throw another Fork at me
you're gonna get rocked
but what makes it so intense is it the
fact that the emotional Stakes have been
set to simmer 40 minutes ago Carmel you
handle mom yeah I'll handle I've never
had a chance to cool and are now coming
to a head in one final scene is it the
fact that this is the first scene where
the cacophony of music and chaotic noise
from the family kitchen has really
quieted down leading to an eerie silence
I love you
okay
I love you too Sean
is it the electric performances from the
entire cast including especially Jamie
Lee Curtis whose character has been
building in intensity this entire time
and seems like they might explode at any
moment those are all definitely key
ingredients but I think the thing that
really pulls this scene together and
makes it so emotionally intense and
almost harrowing to watch is the way
those ingredients are assembled the
person responsible for assembling these
ingredients and serving them to us
searching through sometimes hours of
footage to find exactly the right shot
for each moment was Joanna noggle one of
the editors of the bear there's so many
different layers of like who is feeling
comfortable in this situation who is
feeling stressed who's everyone most
focused on and she expertly draws the
viewer into the emotional intensity of
the scene by prioritizing a specific
kind of shot
foreign
I think by watching people react to what
is going on that's actually how you're
able to build the tension in the scene
and I think that's actually how you're
able to connect where everyone's
headspace is and as much as possible I
was just trying to clock you know sugar
watching Donna Donna watching Michael
you know Cicero watching carmy watching
Michael like just looking for all the
moments of people clocking each other
and make sure that you understood the
shared history and how we got to this
point of other chaos and misery for
everyone
these shots where we're not seeing the
character who's speaking or performing
the primary action but instead the faces
of the characters reacting make up
almost half the running time of this
nearly 14-minute scene to really
underscore just how much narrative work
these kinds of shots are doing consider
the fact that Carmi who's practically
the show's main character doesn't say a
word during this entire scene and yet we
get an entire emotional Arc for his
character just through the reaction
shots we see to craft a scene like this
which is made up of 258 edits Joanna has
to meticulously comb through hours of
footage to find the perfect expression
in a performance that conveys what the
character should be feeling in that
moment but each choice also has to fit
within the flow and pace of the scene
and makes sense within the character's
Arc within the larger story and finding
the right placement and length of a shot
can sometimes come down to just a
fraction of a second because this is our
father's house right Rich my father's
house we have left off the award for all
this effort in this scene is an
emotional pressure cooker we're not just
seeing mounting intensity we're seeing
and feeling all the emotions around the
entire table The Dread awkward
embarrassment anger fear and sadness
about what is playing out in front of
them and to edit like this Joanna has to
intimately understand the story and its
characters is this whole family this way
that like if they don't have a certain
amount of chaos like they literally will
like disappear within themselves and
that's why nobody can help themselves at
dinner when it escalates to the way it
does character Arc emotional subtext and
backstory are usually things that come
up when we're talking about writing
acting and directing but when I talk to
editors who are at the top of their game
I often notice just how frequently the
conversation veers from the technical
into the realm of Story character and
emotion stylistically the bear uses
editing to its fullest potential there
are incredible high intensity chaotic
scenes in the kitchens beautiful
montages and many scenes where they
understand that a perfect edit is none
at all but as cool as all this editing
is it's not style for the sake of itself
it's style that is serving a purpose
either you know pushing the story ahead
or setting up something thematically
Adam Epstein another of the Bears
editors stressed how as flashy as the
bearer's editing gets sometimes it's
always grounded in character and story
it's less about like okay now we're
gonna get crazy and more about let's try
you know as directly as possible to get
something into the interiority of what
of what's going on in Carmen what's
going on it's in in Sydney's head how
Richie is feeling right now I want to
know how exactly do you do this how does
something like shot selection and timing
inform a character's Arc let's look at
how Joanna and Adam used editing to help
construct Richie's character Arc
throughout season two something they
already started setting up in the edit
in season one the first time I think we
really try to create that empathy for
him is in the second episode where
there's that really long phone call
scene he's sitting with Sydney in the
car after being such a jerk to her and
then all of a sudden he gets a phone
call and we just stay on that ankle for
a really long time and we just hold on
his performance and there's so many
places where we could have cut and
instead Chris and Josh and Joanna were
like we should just hang on him this
entire time and seeing him try to be a
father and I think that was like the
first time you're starting to feel a
little bit of empathy for him and in
season two like when he realizes he was
wrong about the mold
we just hold on this really long shot of
him just looking really dejected covered
in you know stuff that fell on him
leaning into that and making those feel
very long and extended as an editor time
is one of the most powerful tools you
have at your disposal lingering on a
piece of performance or an emotional
beat really helps to highlight it for
your audience as something that is
important I think that just
a lot of self clothing he has to live
with himself also like that also creates
some kind of misery so that's also how
you can kind of put these breadcrumbs of
like I think there's more to him there's
more to him he just needs the right
environment to flourish if you changed
nothing else about the show kept all the
dialogue the same but removed all these
shots that Linger on Richie we'd feel
very different as an audience about him
as a character this gave adam a
foundation to work from when he was
editing Forks Richie's big episode from
season two I tried to really lean on the
moments and kind of like the stolen
looks in a lot of his close-ups him kind
of internalizing and taking things in to
really sell Richie's transformation in
Forks one of the key ingredients was
again reaction shots even if it's like a
20 frame shot but if that 20 frame says
like look at me learning and really
taking in what's happening and really
internalizing it the more that the
better even if it goes quick you're
still getting moments that really feel
like you see something Landing in him
but Adam also helped sell this
transformation by expressing externally
what Richie was feeling through the tone
of each scene we're setting up a tone
for something that's going to evolve
over time if Richie was kind of scared
of something what would that look like
and what would that feel like
for Adam creating this tone started with
working on the sound design of this
scene something the editors of the bear
did a lot of
that's it I'd work on yeah yeah not even
close for me as well when I was building
the open to that it was more about the
underlying kind of Sonic bed that would
give you this sense of unease that
almost gave it like a bit of a dream
logic
Chef are we done with the forks the
right sound I think lets you get
visually faster a lot of times because
you're having two senses that are
clocking something it lets you kind of
be a bit more free-flowing in kind of
the experimentation a brief aside here
one of the things you'll notice if you
pay close attention watching the bear is
that each restaurant or kitchen has its
own unique tone and Pace this is
something that's constructed through the
cinematography set design sound design
and of course editing when you're in the
beef in season one it's chaos and it's
messy chaos and then when you're in
Empire which is the high-end Kitchen in
episode two of season one it's intense
but it's almost you know like fascistic
to an extent it's really just nailed
down and everything is an assembly line
and it's like it's fear-based chaos but
back to Forks what's special about this
episode is that the tone of the
restaurant changes throughout the
episode as Richie's perception of the
restaurant changes so while Tony we
start here and we eventually get to here
by the end of the episode we end up here
did you move around a lot
do it's the same location but to us and
to Richie it feels completely different
Adam also used careful editing to help
motivate the transition between these
different tones right after he sees the
teachers get comped uh the meal and the
reaction they have you see you see on
his face just him really taking it in
and then the music sort of like it's a
gentle rise and then this this crazy
Dutch angle of the subway just like in
slow-mo blasting by that then takes us
out to outside and I kind of saw that as
like this is sort of
his mental portal kind of between the
two worlds
for Joanna when it came to editing the
season 2 episode Sunday she used a
different approach in the edit to put us
inside Sydney's head we're starting to
see her like piece together things for
the new menu here it's an abstract
Montage that's expressing the
character's internal landscape that was
something that was really abstract when
it was explained to me I got an initial
cut from this other editor Naya Mani who
did an amazing job pulling out all these
selects and then I kind of messed around
with a bunch of different music figured
out how to condense it so it felt like
we were actually going into Sydney's
brain and kind of seeing those synapses
fire as she's connecting you know seeing
snow falling on the river to then sink
parmesan falling on pasta finding match
Cuts between swatches of colors with
windows so then Square ravioli that all
kind of had similar shapes and then also
putting in photos of like IO actually as
a kid you know as Sydney you know
thinking about her past we put in a shot
of one of the dishes she made in season
one trying to visualize what creative
inspiration and looks like with match
cuts and music and find different
connections between the footage that
made it feel abstract but also relatable
and you could follow that thread as it's
coming to life in her head the script
for that episode because they shouted a
little bit more like a documentary they
didn't get exactly scripted shots we
were also kind of working with what was
captured and we had a ton a ton a ton of
b-roll Chicago footage construction
footage and then on top of that you know
our amazing post team was also pulling
like oh can we see you know architecture
plans for the corn cob Towers like in
downtown Chicago and they were like yep
here's eight options and I was like this
is incredible this one matches the angle
perfectly the first time I saw what
Joanna put together I was really blown
away she's selling herself short I think
a little bit you know obviously you need
the idea and you need the story but that
thing was made in her edit in my opinion
this Montage itself is beautiful but
it's also a beautiful example of how the
show's creators are thinking about
editing as a storytelling device in in
this episode the audience connecting
with Sydney's feeling of inspiration is
a critical story beat but instead of
trying to communicate that through
dialogue or Exposition the episode's
director and writer trusted the editors
to be able to communicate that through
the editing one of the reasons I think
like I've been very lucky to work on
this show is the freedom to experiment
and to try interesting things and to
take what might be a seed of an idea and
really kind of run with it I don't want
to rag on the editors of other movies
and shows editing is an incredibly
difficult profession bad editing often
isn't even the fault of the editors
themselves when I watch a lot of shows
and movies though it really feels like
the editing is often an afterthought
it's treated mostly as a way of just
assembling what was shot and what was in
the script this is a big part of editing
but it misses editing's full potential
neglecting editing is like putting all
your attention into select acting the
perfect ingredients and making sure
they're perfectly cooked and then just
throwing them on a plate without a care
for how they're presented and good
editing requires quality ingredients to
be there the performances the writing
and the cinematography all have to be
doing their job in order for good
editing to take place this Freedom that
the Bears editors had really helped
establish editing as part of the
language of the show and when the
audience gets used to the editing as a
way of expressing the character's
internal space you have more freedom to
do things in the edit that otherwise
might feel kind of jarring for example
when Carmi ends up locked in the freezer
in season two Joanna was able to start
creating a montage of shots from other
episodes that Express what Carmi is
feeling and imagining in that moment and
it doesn't feel like a flashback instead
it feels seamless because the show has
time and time again used insert shots in
this kind of expressionistic way and
when you trust your editors in this way
and give them this kind of freedom and
those editors really understand the
story and character motivations there's
potential for the script to be reshaped
in a way that really benefits the story
in season one episode two they're
talking about the health inspector
potentially coming she's not nice she's
not your friend and Tina and Ibrahim are
outside talking to each other look
around they say no more and then carmy
and Sid are talking about what needs to
happen so we could just have somebody go
and pick it up all these are scripted as
like here's a scene here's a scene
here's a scene they're not scripted as
far as cross-cutting this is more
something that kind of I think Joanna
really did such a great job of having a
track that is playing kind of throughout
and yet you're dipping back into these
conversations but it doesn't feel as
manic as like you know a full
cross-cutting thing and it doesn't feel
as Montage as a full Montage but it's
definitely not just you know divided
scene work yeah we did that again in
episode 208 also there was a scene where
carmy and Fack are in the fridge and
they're talking about Claire and like
they're like what is a girlfriend and
that was filmed as a one take but it was
kind of a long scene and it actually
felt like an instance where the one take
probably wasn't gonna work so that was
something that Megan and I who edited
the episode with me talked about what
else we could like interwave and we
almost like braided together three or
four scenes so we weren't only in this
one take we were kind of coming back to
it as like the tent polls but we had
this one beautiful decemberist song
underneath it and then it was like a
little bit of Fack and carmy in the
fridge then we go to Tina and Richie
then we're back to back and Carmi then
we're with Richie and Sydney and it was
just a way to kind of be in multiple
places at once keep the pace going but
also link them all at the same time too
that type of thing's a great example of
you know when people talk about like
editing being the kind of the final
rewrite it's not scripted like all the
words that are said might be there but
the order and the way that like the
scenes are kind of weaving in and out of
each other that's not on the page so
that's something that you know you got
to kind of experiment and you figure it
out and you find how do you get like the
truest version of what's written but in
a way that allows the tools of
filmmaking to you know to to you know
elevate it to uh what its most ideal
form could be editing when used to its
full potential isn't just a means by
which the story is assembled or the best
performances are chosen it is itself a
big part of the language of filmic
Storytelling the bear showcases what's
possible when everyone from the writers
to the directors to the editors
themselves really understand the
motivation and emotions behind the story
and its characters and how much editing
can bring those characters and their
experiences to life one of the best
examples I've seen recently in a movie
of innovative editing that draws you
into the story is Korean director Park
Chan wook's decision to leave this is an
example of a director who had editing in
mind from the beginning and started
meticulously planning it before they
even started shooting as you can see in
these detailed storyboards for the film
The film's edit matches almost exactly
to what's in this book decision to leave
if you want to watch it is available
right now on mubi my sponsor for this
video if you're like me you've had these
moments where you're flipping endlessly
from streaming service to streaming
service looking for something to watch
and it all just starts to look the same
mubi really breaks up that monotony with
its focus on excellent curation here
you'll find Classics indie films
Festival Favorites and I think the best
selection of International Cinema that
you can get online in the US you can
watch decision to leave and explore the
rest of the library for free right now
when you sign up for my extended 30-day
free trial by going to movie.com
thomasflight mubi is available all
around the world so sign up and discover
some amazing cinema by going to mubi.com
thomasflight or by clicking on the link
on the screen thanks again to mubi for
sponsoring this video
foreign
[Music]